[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous dans son caddie
ce matin michel pelletier vous êtes le
directeur de la mer en martinique et
vous êtes avec nous pour évoquer ce
projet de parc naturel marais il s'agit
avant tout de faire en sorte que tout le
monde puisse décider de ce que nous
pouvons faire de cette hausse ayant qui
nous entourent monsieur pelletier
oui c'est un peu ça c'est pour que les
auditeurs comprenne bien il faut il faut
remonter à une dizaine d'années en avant
pourrait bien comprendre ce qu'est la
mer la mer c'est d'abord on n'y pense
pas souvent mais c'est la régularité la
triste du climat c'est grâce à nos
courants océaniques que nous avons les
climats que nous avons ici les
dérèglements climatiques arrive c'est
aussi parce qu'il ya des dérèglements
dans les puits parfois dans les océans
la deuxième chose on y pense là pour le
coup c'est que la mère fournit des
protéines de nombreux habitants et pays
en particulier dans les pays en voie de
développement donc c'est évidemment là
les produits halieutiques de la pêche
c'est très important
et puis la mer on n'y pense pas non plus
c'est une réserve de carbone la mer
stockent le carbone et ça évite
évidemment que ce carbone se retrouvent
dans l'atmosphère
et puis la mer ça produit l'oxygène
voyez la mer c'est tout un ensemble qui
rend des services à l'humanité dans son
ensemble à la terre on trouve les
terriens qui la regarde on est il faut
absolument la protéger c'est pour ça que
il ya une dizaine d'années pendants les
grenelle vous savez ces grands exercices
et grand débat démocratique de
l'environnement et puis ensuite de la
mère précisément il a été décidé de
de créer ces aires marines protégées ces
fameux parc naturel marin 6 l à peu près
oui alors depuis on a effectivement créé
une dizaine le parc martinique et sera
normalement le dixième parc parce que
c'est ces aires marines protégées vont
justement assurer et garantir les
services rendus par les océans et
services rendus par la mer et la france
vous savez à une responsabilité très
lourde très importante dans ce qu'elle
est une des plus grandes puissances
maritimes vient exactement la deuxième
alors comment ça va se formaliser ce
parc naturel marin de la martinique en
ce moment il y a une une enquête
publique les martiniquais peuvent se
rendre en mairie pour regarder comment
les choses peuvent se passer
concrètement pour nous ça veut dire quoi
nous qui sommes entourés d'eau et ben ce
parc va changer quoi dans notre
quotidien
alors ce parc il va d'abord essayer de
mieux comprendre ce qu'est la mer parce
qu'effectivement vous l'avais un peu dit
les martiniquais sont parfois un peu
éloigné de ses sujets mais pas que les
martiniquais finalement la mer c'est la
nouvelle frontière on connaît moins de
choses de la mer qu'on connaît de
l'espace voyez qu'on a un fort besoin
d'investissements de la connaissance
donc j'ai envie tu pourrais vous
répondre
déjà pour commencer ça va devrait nous
permettre de nous apporter un certain
nombre d'informations sur un élément que
l'on côtoie que l'on voit que dans
lequel on se baigne tous les dimanches
et et que finalement reste assez
méconnue de nous tous
alors on va sa forme et on va apprendre
va étudier on va préserver
on va réparer on va sanctionner ce que
fait l'homme sur ce milieu tellement
fragile il faut le rappeler
exactement parce que si on crée un parc
marin la martinique c'est parce que là
le patrimoine maritime et est très
important parti de biodiversité un
biologique
et très riche à la martinique mais il de
même le patrimoine culturel est aussi
très riche
vous savez que la mère représentation de
véhicules ensemble de représentations à
lamartine qui sont souvent assez sombre
d'ailleurs assez noir 1 il faut le il
faut le rappeler est donc l'idée c'est
effectivement de de mettre en valeur ce
patrimoine alors le mettre en valeur et
aussi comme vous venez de le dire de le
restaurer et de le valoriser parce que
il peut être en danger il peut être en
danger par tout un tas de facteurs les
usagers que nous sommes nous prenons pas
suffisamment soin de la mer en
particulier comme millions les bateaux
ou quand nous jetons des ordures à la
mer par exemple il peut y avoir des
marées noires aussi on en a suffisamment
parlé il ya quelques années on va de nos
chiffres monsieur paul 6 75 % des
logements martinique sont situées le
long de nos côtes
ah oui exactement ça c'est un gros sujet
c'est que malheureusement la mère est
victime bien souvent de pollution qui
viennent de la terre ce qu'on appelle
des pollutions terrestres ou telluriques
elle y est tout simplement à
l'écoulement des eaux et donc
effectivement se classe que les communes
sont concernées même le saint-esprit le
grand monde qui sont des communes de
l'intérieur des terres mais elles sont
concernées par ce que nous avons
quarante trois rivières sont 43 ravine
cent soixante et une rivière qui est ben
forcément arrive à la mer le moment
exactement tout tout arrive à la mer et
ce parc va permettre justement je
l'espère en tout cas de 2 crée aussi une
cette conscience qui manque parfois un
en particulier de nos responsables qui
doivent aider des habitants évidemment
qu'ils doivent tenir compte finalement
de tout ce qu'ils font à terre a une
répercussion en mer c'est ça qu'il faut
voir qu'on vous jeter un mégot dans la
rue et bien souvent ce mégots il arrive
en mer et il peut étouffer une tortue ou
voyez il peut avoir des conséquences est
finalement assez grave
surtout si on les répète des millions de
fois donc c'est vrai que le parc aura
une vigilance particulière pour tout ce
qui se passe à terre ça peut paraître un
peu paradoxal mais et devra de rendre
des avis par exemple sur un certain
nombre de projets d'aménagement en
particulier pourquoi pas des projets
d'aménagement
l'organiste hic pour vérifier
effectivement qu'ils n'ont pas d'impact
sur notre mère alors ces derniers temps
on a beaucoup vu les secteurs
économiques se dire que la mer
représente potentiellement martinez qui
n'est pas suffisamment développée on
parle par exemple du tourisme de
nautique du tourisme de croisière des
activités qu'on pourrait mettre sur pied
encore par exemple pour réparer les
bateaux tout cela est ce que ce parc
aura par exemple un regard surtout ses
activités économiques qui pourront se
déployer autour de notre île oui alors
le parc il aurait pas forcément pour
mission de développer les activités mais
il aura pour mission que le rôle de la
police quoi où et enfin il sera là
plutôt comme conseilleurs c'est à dire
comme quelqu'un qui va participer au
projet en amont et qui va orienter les
activités les usages vers des activités
durables faire en sorte que lorsque vous
je sais pas vous partez en mer avec un
jet ski vous vous savez comment se
comporter vis-à-vis des cétacés et voyez
donc qu'il fera pas mal de pédagogie et
il l'aidera il fera pas tout tous seuls
il aidera aussi les acteurs actuels
privés comme publics qui interviennent
en mer pour faire en sorte que leurs
activités deviennent plus durable est ce
que vous pourriez intervenir par exemple
chez un garagiste qui ne respectent pas
les règles les normes sur
l'environnement un garagiste de
l'intérieur des terres qui par exemple
jetterait toutes les usagers dans un
cours d'eau oui en tout cas il pourrait
y avoir une discussion ensemble au sein
du parc du conseil de gestion et le
conseil de les acteurs du parc pour
qu'ils soient des acteurs élus un membre
du conseil de gestion vous ou même les
représentants jeudi les salariés de ce
parc pourront effectivement engagé un
dialogue parce que ce qui est important
de comprendre c'est finalement pour y
arriver
pour arriver à protéger de notre mère il
faut de la réglementation mais ça c'est
les pouvoirs réglementaires qui
garderont ce pouvoir le parc n'aura pas
de pouvoir réglementaire le parc ça sera
vraiment un lieu où on essaye de
discuter de ces sujets on fasse de la
sensibilisation en fasse comprendre
finalement de la pédagogie de la
prévention et la pédagogie je pense que
c'est le meilleur e meilleur système le
maire outils pour pour arriver à nos
fins c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que la
mère reste ce potentiel que vous venez
de lire sur un potentiel de croissance
alors qu'est ce qui sera la surface de
ce pape
alors ce sera désert les les autres
limite des eaux territoriales
martiniquaise alors ça sera un peu plus
que ça ça sera là ça sera le la merde
sur lesquels la france à la souveraineté
donc ce qu'on appelle en jargon un peu
technique la zone économique exclusive
qui représente à peu près quarante et un
mille kilomètres carrés 42 mille
kilomètres carrés
donc finalement toutes les eaux
françaises autour de la martinique ça
représente un peu plus que le territoire
de la suisse pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée
comment ça va se passer avec n'ouvre
c'est qu'ils sont même vraiment très
très très très proche de non je parle de
sainte lucie de la dominique
on m'a souvent eu des problèmes parce
que ben vous savez pas il n'y a pas de
limite géographique lorsqu'on est sur
l'eau on peut être tantôt d'un côté
tantôt de l'autre en quelques secondes
est ce que vous allez en famille des
discussions à castries 0 soit propos 2
de ce parc
en principe il ya effectivement le lamer
n'a pas de frontières physiques on peut
pas empêcher une pollution au gré des
courants de se retrouver dans les hauts
de deux ans tel ou un tel
en revanche elle pour les usagers de la
mer pour les pour les marins pour les
navires elle est là des frontières vous
n'avez pas la possibilité comme sept
pêcheurs martinique et d'aller pêcher
dans les eaux de la dominique même si ça
peut arriver sur le banc de dmfu on a
depuis d'ailleurs rendre moins de
problèmes ces dernières années mais on
en a eu des problèmes de territoire a
donc effectivement le parc il faut ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que ça sera un
outil de plus à la disposition des
martiniquais un outil opérationnel qui
va réaliser des choses
et parmi les choses à réaliser il ya
peut-être se et avez raison il ya
peut-être cette coopération qu'il faudra
faire avec nos voisins dans le domaine
environnemental c'est à dire toujours
dans le domaine du parc c'était essayer
de faire en sorte que nous au soit en
bon état et un des critères du bon état
de la mer c'est la connectivité c'est
justement ce lien parce que la mère n'a
pas de frontière entre l'est évidemment
les uns les autres en fonction la
chronologie en fonction de l'altimétrie
évidemment de la mère et/ou des choses
comme ça oui
l'enquêté publique c'est jusqu'au 2
février ensuite ce sera quoi le timing
pour la création officielle de ce parc
naturel mari de la martinique de février
oui sachant que c'est un processus qui a
commencé depuis quelques années un qui
qui s'achève une concertation qui
s'achève maintenant c'est vraiment laid
martin
qui doit se prendre connaissance le
document je crois et est assez
pédagogique et très très bien
personnellement je recommande à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent
allez le voir il est magnifique on
apprend beaucoup de choses sur notre
pays exactement il met en valeur aussi
la richesse de la martinique
et puis il faut y aller le commissaire
enquêteur rendra son rapport le préfet
lui-même de la martinique rendra un avis
à la mise de l'environnement et s'il
s'agira le ministre ensuite deux ans
avec la somme d'autres ministres de la
défense des outre-mer bien sûr de
prendre le décret une dernière question
très rapidement ce parc naturel marin ce
sera de la création d'emplois pour notre
martinique ou bien ce sera du
redéploiement dans les services de
l'état oui ça sera des nouveaux moyens
donc ça sera des moyens humains des
moyens budgétaires qui nous permettront
d'avancer qui nous manquent aux gens un
peu aujourd'hui et donc ça sera une
opportunité aussi pour des jeunes
martiniquais je l'espère de pouvoir de
pouvoir s'investir dans le milieu qui
les environne et qu'ils chérissent merci
michel pelletier d'avoir été ce matin
avec nous dans son camion a précisé le
directeur de la mer en martinique
[Musique]